félicien kabuga c'était le numéro un des
fugitifs
il est considéré comme le criminel de
guerre le plus recherché au monde
derrière ben laden
le fbi américain veut ni 5 millions de
dollars sur sa tête
pour le surnommé l'insaisissable pas
moins de cinq procureurs se sont succédé
au tribunal pénal international pour le
rwanda
en rêvant de son arrestation il est dit
qu il avait 28 identités différentes
loin de nous l'idée de penser qu'il
était en france et certains le pensent
et mort tout simplement
pour brut on vous raconte l'histoire
dans des cerveaux du génocide rwandais
il s'appelle félicien kabuga depuis 26
ans kabuga est traqué par la justice
internationale pour crimes de guerre et
génocide
de mars à juillet 1994 un million de
tutsis sont exterminés par les
extrémistes hutus
[Musique]
j'avais 17 ans en 1994 quand jeune stay
lieu
j'habitais dans le quartier de miami
lambeaux et avec mes parents donc nous
avons quitté la maison familiale
tous les tutsis essayer de sauver leur
beau temps était caché par des voisins
et quelques jours après nous avons pu
quitter le monde du vélo dans le fossé
que je laisse pas d'étonner
[Musique]
les souvenirs de jeunesse en entendant
le nom de kabuga défaitisme kabuga c'est
juste que c'était un homme extrêmement
riche
c'était carrément devenu un nom commun
donc quelqu'un qui devenait qui est
terrifiant des interviews
le cal sa fortune il l'a mise au service
de la préparation des esprits au
génocide et cette radio des mille
collines qui est connu et qui est le
symbole de ce qu'on a appelé les médias
delà de la haine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était une radio avec une musique
entraînante que on mettait une chez nous
on écoutait il mettait lui koffi olomidé
des sous
[Applaudissements]
au milieu de certaines chansons
entraînantes que nous écoutions tous
diffuser des messages de haine où il
n'appelait pas les tutsis des soucis il
les appelait par des noms d'animaux
c'est des cancrelats des cafards la
haine peut conduire à des crimes de
masse à condition que le meurtre soit
autorisé et encouragé et kabuga en cela
et à participer par la direction de la
radio mille collines une radio qui est
qui peut être entendu dans chaque recoin
du du rwanda c'est le seul média pour
par lequel les gens s'informent on
branche la radio dès le matin elle reste
en sourdine même quand on fait d'autres
activités cette radio a continué à
donner quotidiennement en direct sur
l'antenne
la liste des personnes à tuer
on pouvait dire telle église
il ya encore des cafards qui sont là bas
mais les gens aussi appelé pour pour
pour la délation donc c'est ça été un
accélérateur inimaginable au nahd
génocide
les miliciens avec la radio dans une
main la machette dans l'autre
[Applaudissements]
kabuga c'est l argentier le grand
argentier du génocide contre les tutsi
c'est lui qui a mis en place les milices
interahamwe
attendons
c'est la milice est innée l'armée c'est
à dire ceux qui attaquent ensemble au
qui combattent ensemble
cette milice c'est le cheville ouvrière
du génocide
ces hommes aux civils peuvent installer
des barrages arrêter des gens vont
vérifier leur identité donc leur et plus
et bien sûr tu es en toute impunité
c'est une particule à tête du jeune fils
quand même contre les tutsis sait que
c'est le plus meurtrier aussi rapidement
on parle de dix mille morts par jour
sans des grands moyens industriels
félicien kabuga et non dans ces actes
d'accusation il est soupçonné d'avoir
acheté des machettes
[Musique]
c'est son entreprise qui fera à l'ordre
d'importation 25 tonnes importées de
chine
donc il n'a pas besoin d'être sur le
devant de la scène
il dirige et tire les ficelles il
conçoit il planifie
dans l'acte d'accusation il ya toute une
déclinaison des chefs de génocide
génocide à différents titres comme
participants directs au génocide et sous
différentes formes de complicité ou
d'incitation kabuga est inculpé depuis
1997 pour génocide et crimes contre
l'humanité
pendant 26 ans félicien kabuga fui la
justice internationale il est vu au
congo au rwanda puis en europe en suisse
en belgique en allemagne mais jamais
arrêter félicien kabuga brouille les
pistes jusqu'en janvier 2020 les
enquêteurs français ont alors une
information kabuga se cacherait en
banlieue parisienne
[Musique]
je suis le connais eric héraud
auparavant je commandais l'office
central de lutte contre les crimes
contre l'humanité pendant trois ans à
partir de janvier 2020 on a commencé à
voir des informations petit peu plus
précise et en février on a fait une
réunion à europol
en fait on a une information qui a les
anglais comme quoi hein et membres de la
famille quitte le territoire anglais et
vient en europe
nous on a repris en fait là la balise
ans consomme téléphone en fait la
personne se rendait à asnières on avait
quasiment tous les jours un des membres
de la famille qui faisait bip et le
relais
ce qui nous amène à penser que asnières
on a quelque chose qui est intéressant
un des neveux de kabuga louer un
appartement à ce niveau là
le 16 mai matin on était quasiment sûr à
90% qu'il était derrière laborde
on suit en fait la colonne entre
guillemets une colonne d'assaut ils
savent précisément par où ils doivent
passer pour éviter d'être décelé c'est
pour ça qu'on est passé par les sous
sols par le garage pour remonter de
l'autre côté pour éviter d'être vu et
ensuite on remonte dans la cage
d'escalier pour arriver devant la porte
là ils ont un vérin est prévue à cet
effet qui permet en deux secondes de
faire sauter la porte
[Musique]
dans l'appartement effectivement on a
deux personnes on a le fils de
de kalouga et un autre personnage qui
d'emblée n10 appelé antoine tonga et en
fait on sait très bien que c'est vers
kabuga en fait le sentiment c'est que
quand on rentre dans cet appartement
pour lui l'ouverture de la porte
le rideau tombe c'est fini la traque
s'est finie 26 ans de cavale et
maintenant il va falloir
s'expliquer c'est un vieillard de cris
de 80 ans donc c'est bien pour ça que
ces crimes sont considérées comme étant
à prescriptibles et que finalement quel
que soit l'âge ils puissent être
absolument sûr qu'un jour là ils vont
être rattrapés par la patrouille
le fait qu'il soit arrêté et que nos
enfants nous ne vivent pas dans un monde
où des kabuga se baladent impunément
c'est absolument indispensable
[Musique]